he's got one of the three Famer
but then he corrects it right after he
goes hit a line drive into the lower
deck yup it's just not the most
real-time accurate but it's accurate
when it's all said and done exactly by
the way have you ever done you must have
done play-by-play right I did by the way
Larry David here on the Rich Eisen show
a season 9 of curb after six-year hiatus
thank goodness it's back and good to see
you here I did about nine games for ESPN
that's it wow they let me out of the
Sports Center studio just do a handful
of games but did you you did gangs
before that though no is the only time
everyone yeah yeah you never did play by
playing your life no I'm they start me
out there that's insane
well I didn't hey be the first game I
did this is a true story
it was a one-nothing final between the
Padres and expose that went 10 innings
you did baseball to do all that
blathering between oh my god that's
really something and my analyst had
never done it either chili Davis
remember chili Davis from the Yankees
know what chili oil is the giant first
joined the Yankees yeah and the general
did you ever want to do play-by-play I
did when I was a kid what do you mean
when I was like a kid like 8 9 10 years
old 12 years old just by yourself in a
room or something like sitting in front
of the TV you know trying to do it yeah
and out I wasn't was it good I don't
think I was very good and my mother said
to me you're not gonna be a baseball
announcer what do you think you are a
baseball you're not special Larry you're
not gonna be an announcer where's Ben
Scully your guy basically like no Alan
you know for the Yankees drivers of
course Mel Allen was the greatest yeah
yeah and then he would always do the
this week in baseball I remember that
stuff yeah 70s in the air yes
good old Mel Allen so that's how you
became a Yankee fan is back in the day
and kanyenke vanka's my brother my older
brother by four and a half years was a
Yankee fan right and so he was the night
convinced why I became a Yankee the only
two Yankee fans in Brooklyn yeah because
it was the Dodgers Dorothy all right
pretty much there
so it led to a lot of ill-will ruffians
on the street would take you down the
giant stars ruffians I wasn't taken down
because I was a Yankee fan but I did get
in a lot of argument ok Larry David here
on the Rich Eisen show um so how did you
become a jet fan because normally it's
giant Yankee right I was a giant fan and
I still root for the Giants ok but then
when when Namath came along I was so
taken with him and the team and I loved
watching him play that I became Jets
okay and then and then you never jumped
off that average I could never jumped
off now cuz so many opportunities so
many by the way the worst thing to
happen to the just this year was McCown
being good the what that's the worst
thing that could've happened to the
jokes yeah so what a tortured mind of
the jet fan yes because Owen 16 would
normally be worse because now he's just
gonna make us mediocre you know he'll
get us too many wins to get a
quarterback he's 38 where's the future
with him we and if he was bad at least
we could see what petty had or
Hackenberg had now we'll never get to
see them we'll never get to see them
we'll never get to draft a good
quarterback okay and so now we'll have
account for another year in lieu and and
what exactly where do we go
by the way mm-hmm totally simpatico with
you yeah because we were talking about
before Brady Brady Oh last longer than
McCown he'll still be winning games for
New England is the idea is to try and
beat him you know and the rest of the
team is good enough the defense is is
good enough right they can win maybe
five games possibly six which
quarterback that's playing here right
now in Los Angeles would you take which
one would you take golf or I mean a
rosin or darn 'old which one which one I
gotta go with the I gotta go with the
the heap come on rosin in New York
that's it they're made for each other
so just alone yes but it would just be
the jets luck taking on the New England
Patriots it would be Yom Kippur right
Larry yes
you'll be on holiday on the biggest
Ocean Koufax in politics it makes it all
you know to this point where I got to
tell you you know when there's a
broadcast I I sit it out you know cuz if
Koufax out at a World Series game is
that so yeah how do i how do i broadcast
i remember Jerry once once sat out a
taping me really yeah I I said are you
nuts
what do you do what so what it's
interesting we had Jerry on the show
just a couple weeks ago Larry and I
asked him how come Steinbrenner himself
never appeared on Seinfeld and he said
Steinbrenner shot a scene but it was so
bad you cut it is that a true story true
story yeah what was so bad about it
we brought him out I think for the last
show of the 95 season I'm not quite sure
when it was but he flew out on his
private jet to do the show and flew back
that day and okay he did it and then I
go into editing and I'm watching the
show and oh my god he was so awful he
was so bad it was you couldn't use it it
was much better from behind with my
voice you know then actually seeing the
real the real guy doing it right so that
was a scene where he was with Costanza
with he was with Elaine in a restaurant
I think okay and I had to call him up
and tell him he was cut how'd that go I
called Yankee Stadium I said I want to
talk to mr. Stein Brenner's Larry David
you got a phone okay I said mr.
Steinbrenner it's Larry David calling
from the Seinfeld show yes yes Larry
what is it I said I said I'm sorry to
tell you this he said come on you can
tell me I'm a big boy I can take it you
know by you slip right back in right and
I said I'd see you know I've been cut
from the show and I
I said it's not your fault but it's just
dinner the scene wasn't working and that
was it
how do you take it mm-hmm he was a big
boy he took it well this is some beef he
told you how he was gonna take it yeah
George Steinbrenner in lane I would
never have guessed I would have thought
that there would have to have been a
Costanza George Bowman you know there
was an Elaine scene I don't know it may
have been a George scene I'm not sure I
don't remember how did you enjoy playing
Steinbrenner you have a blast doing that
oh yeah it was fun yeah I had yeah
what's your favorite one were you were
Steinbrenner
what was it I think probably something I
remember the calzone yeah George how to
get the girl out calzones yeah that's as
great as it gets from back in the day
and then you had Buck Showalter on and
and Paul O'Neill Seinfeld said paulownia
was the best actor of all the Yankees
that came on I don't think I was there
for that show you'd already you'd
already already left
yeah you already left that was in the
last two years Larry David here on the
Rich Eisen show I want to take a break
and when we come back in 60 seconds you
told a story off the air based on you
went on our Callaway corner and you
showed off your puting style which I
thought was a joke but you're saying
that really is your real putting style
yes getting basically down on the floor
as close as you can yes the putter head
I go low okay and you told me with whom
you were golfing the other day was
Barack Obama you're playing golf with
the president you know I hate to
name-drop that's back in 60 seconds with
that I want to talk curb Salman Rushdie
was a phenomenal it was great
cameo yeah words I never thought you'd
probably ever say about anything you
were done that Salman Rushdie was
terrific
Yeah right he was great and then and
then we'll put you in the if you will
judge in jury box of social situations
that we have all come across that I'm
really looking forward okay and you let
us know if what's right in what is well
I cannot say enough wonderful things
about this setup I just very comfortable
okay this thing I could do without in my
face yeah yeah it's a little tight it's
a little tight
a little tight but it gets it has a nice
radio kind of feel to it you know it's a
song times we got to give the nod to the
radio as well the studio space you have
here okay but we get the check mark the
LD check absolutely if I'm George dick
fantastic we're back in 60 seconds Larry
David here in the Rich Eisen
[Music]
Larry David here in the Rich Eisen show
studio Curb Your Enthusiasm is back
episode 3 of 10 just aired a Sunday
night on HBO 10:00 eastern time back
after a six-year hiatus LD I'm telling
you it is as good as ever
thank you and the episode in this past
week with the two the two celebrity
cameos Elizabeth Banks supposedly
playing herself yeah she was brilliant
by the way sup is first time in the
history of the show mmm where I actually
was almost completely silent for an
entire scene the scene in Jeff's house
yes mmm when I bring her in yes she's
doing all that I'm not saying a word was
that it was that ad-lib all that stuff
oh yeah yeah how much of it is ad-libbed
kirb most of it 90% would you say if you
had a participant you know we're sports
people we got to put percentages on
things yeah at least yeah who's the one
who cracks you up the most where it's
difficult for you to get through scene
oh boy I don't know that's hard to say
I'll tell you the one that I would guess
Oh JB Smoove
yeah JB yeah yeah you know we send him
it's been how many years in a row it's
been three years in a row where we've
done yeah this will be the third coming
up these are our correspondent at the
Super Bowl media day we send him in
there with the Rich Eisen show Mike flag
and just let him but the ruckus uh-huh
right close and more people interview
him than he interviews people yeah yeah
he's he's amazing Susie Essman would
have been number two in terms of
cracking you up what this you know I
really left when people curse me I don't
know why it's always been that way right
remember that wrestler in the in the
second season who came over to my car
window hmm because I was just pretending
I was shooting his kids and in the back
I was following them in the car and I
was driving enough and his kids were
shooting me they were in the backseat
facing me off I was shooting them and
then he stops the car he gets out and
comes over the window man that guy he
said he just broke me up he broke you up
the one time that I was fortunate enough
to be on the set years ago where I had a
cameo I get you know tweets from time to
time where's your camera
as a cameo is that Jeff Garlin's
daughter's Bat Mitzvah oh yes that was
the episode where interestingly enough
you had something stuck in your throat
and to be safe for work for this program
we won't say exactly what was done in
your throat and why but you couldn't get
through a scene about talking about what
was in your throat it took it took about
yeah ten takes for you to get through
something like that no I'm really lucky
I it's been incredible it's been
incredible rise me with a lot of laughs
well how did you get Salman Rushdie to
appear to talk about the fought wall and
then say the things that's well he said
we wrote the show before we asked him I
there was only one way I could god I
didn't want to have to wear that
mustache and that wig every week I had
to get out of the fat was somehow yes
and I thought well this is this is the
best way to get him because he got
through it hmm so let's let's get him so
man we wrote the show and then then I
just
I called him you yeah personally yeah
you got his number
yes I had met him a couple of times I
also heard he was a fan of the show um I
think he may have told me that when I
met him so um I called him he was game
immediately he was yes you told him the
the concept of yes I told him the
concept he was he was game to do it okay
so what was who was tougher to get by
the way big Yankee fan to see are you
seriously yeah he likes John sterling
Salman Rushdie I thought I don't know
[Laughter]
never had that conversation with him but
so what which was a more difficult cameo
to to get Salman Rushdie or Bill Buckner
from that episode where he had to relive
Bill Buckner how did that go about how
did you go about getting Bill Buckner uh
I called him so you're the one who's
yeah you you don't leave it up to
somebody else well when we need the the
big ones yeah do they Rivera yeah thank
you clothes exactly I'm no I called bill
and I was very nervous about that call
because
I want I was so desperate to do that
show I love that episode it's brilliant
but Mookie Wilson and here yeah and but
you had to describe to him what you
wanted him to do right yes
okay yes he didn't want to do it at
first I really had to stay on the phone
with him and he had to think about it
and then I had a send it to him to read
and and and then his daughter was it was
an actress and and I said well what you
know we could put your daughter on the
show too
his daughters a good actress okay she
was in Los Angeles and I think when I
offered that the quid pro quo the quid
pro quo so you Pro quote him I quote him
yes well he quitted you I don't know
what know which was either you either
quitted you or you Pro quote him yeah
I'm trying to figure that one out but he
said yeah and it was it was just one of
my all-time favorite episodes it's great
again Larry David here for Kirby by the
way there was a draft mmm where he
dropped the baby are you serious yeah
yeah how did you not keep that I
couldn't do it I knew it
you know I that was hilarious him
dropping the baby yeah okay that was
hilarious but I couldn't do it the other
one made me cry a little bit when he
caught the baby mm-hmm
and so uh yeah I I had it right we had a
redeemer before we get to our endeavor
that we like doing with the other way
yes fantastic I build honor one of the
great guys I've ever heard you hear
about that and obviously there was that
moment history and and and the crazy
thing too is when you see the the Hank
Aaron home run off of off of howling
he's the leftfielder that goes over his
head I was that right yes he's had a
ball go over his head and yeah but he
couldn't catch that ball that one he
couldn't catch no no yeah no but I I
shouldn't bring that up but anyway so
before we get to putting you in the
judge and jury box about social
situations yes bring him on I'll do that
in a second but you were
you you play golf no I know you don't
want a name drop but I'll do it for you
so would Obama
when did you play golf with him we
played on Friday so just like last week
yeah all right
what is it I mean what is it like when
the putts are like two feet away I mean
do you give him a presidential gimme or
what he kind of winds a little bit about
it yeah yeah yeah he goes he goes boy
I'm hearing crickets you know like he's
waiting for you to say let me give him
the putt yeah you know these putts these
guineas and all that yeah it leads to a
lot of fighting all the time the people
I play with because sometimes oh I gave
you that one you're not giving me this
one well that one was closer you know so
there's all these fights about it yeah
so I like a leather rule and and I I
like to adhere to the leather rule
inside the leather of the handle of the
blessed exactly so you're getting down
and putting the the yes the putter head
into the cup into the cup and measuring
yes even with once upon a time the
leader of the free world that does not
matter for you oh no I don't care no
yeah yeah that's impressive
but he doesn't do that he doesn't do
that easy no he doesn't he doesn't play
leather he does oh that's good he's
pretty generous and I got a say okay
yeah well he said you would expected
what cuz he's a liberal
yeah I'm sure if you believe with Trump
he would probably make you put in for
six inches who won meant Friday
he took $120 from me no kidding no
kidding
yeah he's good he took a buck 20 from
yes who else was playing is there
anybody else that we would know that was
playing Ari Emanuel okay that makes
sense and Chuck Lorre a writer yeah Oh
mr. two and a half men right to a half
men yeah all four you were out there yes
so were you paired with Obama were you
paired against him or is he just so what
what game do you play on no it was I was
against him and took $120 from me and I
also had an individual with him Joe I
had two head yeah all total your $120
like yes Barack Obama taking money from
Larry David sick about it
are you ready to play judge and jury
early social situations here we go Larry
David we've done this before with you
yeah I've got three social situations
you are the judge and jury as to what is
done okay now we get on this one with
you before you've come to the right guy
I know we've done this with you before
back in the day but it's kind of a new
audience it's been several years so the
first one is destination weddings okay
decimation I say to my wife we're going
to a destination wedding we should not
give a present because my presence is my
present
what do you say Larry first of all where
is the wedding how far is it another
country okay you don't even go you don't
go but what's a close family friend I
don't care I am NOT flying 14 hours on a
plane yes to somebody's wedding I'm not
gonna do that even if it's a nice
destination where it's a nice hotel and
you're set up no 14 hours on a plane you
you can't even breathe
come on so what would be the what the
distance from your house that you were
now and a half by car that's it no plane
that you didn't okay you don't get on
planes for weddings right okay out of
the question so what are you putting me
in me on the RSVP do you write something
no can't can't can't make it too far
that's it that's it yeah I just leave it
at that
no follow-up phone call follow-up
nothing no okay
they have to know when they're inviting
you they're putting you'd they're making
you go on a plane personally you're
spending $20,000 to get there that's
what I'm saying why do I need candle
sticks or a gravy boat exactly if you're
flying to Europe my god and a hotel yeah
it's gonna cost $15,000 yes yeah how's
that for a present that's what so but
you're saying is just cut out that
middleman and just you're not even going
you know don't even go okay your social
situation number two for you Larry here
you're going over to somebody's house
okay all right for for you're watching a
fight for instance how come you're not
writing on the show with these well
we'll get to that in a second so you're
going into somebody's house for let's
say the fight the Mayweather
to fight this island to one of our
producers cool okay
they brought desserts fight ends
nobody's touched the desserts they like
these desserts is it okay to take the
desserts home well we did this on
Seinfeld you did yeah the marble rye
well the marble okay Danny did he not
want to take it home he didn't want to
take it back in there George's dad Jerry
Stiller that's right okay he wanted to
take the marble ride home right guess he
did yeah so what are you wrong well I
mean they didn't try to fish the marble
right out to make sure that it came back
but okay here's the thing
yes you bring it over do they know you
brought it over yes they do well if they
know you brought it over then you can't
take it but what if nobody's tried it
you know it's not like a bottle of wine
a bottle wine could be savored later on
it's still usable you bring it to the
host right that's true the host thought
hmm it's different those two see then
you could sneak out of it so if the host
never saw it it's on the table and
there's no note yeah that's when you
could take it if you think if you think
you're not gonna get caught yeah then
you could take it problem is though
Larry is you never know what was looking
beyond the sky that's true that's the
that's the gamble yeah but if the host
sees it mmm you can't take it all right
the last one for you Larry
LD shoes off on a plane do you have a
problem with somebody on a plane I have
a big problem with it yeah yeah keep
them on okay and don't wear the shorts
either that's the destination you do not
want to be sitting next to somebody in
shorts that is the worst so why is it
you have a problem of people taking the
shoes off on a plane you know don't make
yourself it's not your house all right
you're outside you're in public I don't
want to say I don't want to see your
socks and God forbid you have a little
odor down there who needs that right and
I don't even want to know if you do have
it exactly it's close quarters come on
take a couple minutes keep your shoes on
so those who take their shoes off with
shorts on and then put their socks feet
up on the bulkhead Oh God Almighty no oh
God that is out yes no-fly list or no
please yeah Larry before I let you go
the response has been so great for this
current season of Curb Your Enthusiasm
are you thinking about another season
right now I'm thinking about it not
committing to it as of yet but I'm
thinking about it but you're thinking
about it which I know is part of the
process knowing you in the process that
that has to happen first for that staff
yeah I mean it's a um you know it's it's
you guys climbing Mount Everest again
you know it's it's a big slug to do it
but you're thinking about I'm thinking
about it yeah okay so you're saying
there's a chance
absolutely fantastic Larry love having
you on here and by the way if I do it it
won't be a 5-year in-between wait can't
happen I can't have that speaking on
behalf of everyone who loves the show
cannot I'll be on crutches by that
that's the way you puck so good to see
you Larry good to see Larry David of
Curb Your Enthusiasm here on the show
we're back to wrap wish I could get a
tape of that first baseball game you did
I really want to help I could get it
yeah oh yeah I want to hear fantastic
it's it's it is probably three up three
down for the Expos and the Padres it
wasn't scintillating they're not writing
home about it the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
[Music]